nos populations d'abeilles domestiques
sont elles en train de décliner depuis
plusieurs années agriculteurs et
amoureux de la nature tire la sonnette
d'alarmé
nos abeilles vont mal cette année c'est
même l'hécatombe en bretagne plus de la
moitié des abeilles domestiques n'ont
pas passé l'hiver
pourtant quand on demande au ministre
français de l'agriculture ce qu'il
compte mettre en place pour aider des
apiculteurs
ils nous répondent les dispositifs de
surveillance dont disposent les pouvoirs
publics aujourd'hui ne permettent pas à
cette heure de corroborer une
généralisation de cette dégradation
donc selon les chiffres officiels les
populations d'abeilles domestiques ne
serait pas en déclin dans l'hexagone
pour vérifier ça regardons l'évolution
du nombre de ruches française on observe
une forte chute début des années 2010
depuis leur nombre se stabilise ces
chiffres ne permet toutefois pas de
connaître l'état de santé des abeilles
pourquoi parce que l'apiculteur est
avant tout un éleveur quand il subit des
pertes
il remplace ses colonies il faut donc
s'intéresser aux pertes de colonies et
là la réalité est un peu plus difficile
à cerner le problème est qu'il n'existe
pas de système de surveillance de la
mortalité des abeilles au niveau
national mais l'on peut quand même avoir
une idée de la situation grâce à
plusieurs études scientifiques financés
par les pouvoirs publics français et
européens
tout montre un taux de mortalité trop
élevé les apiculteurs le reconnaissent
ils peuvent accepter de perdre 10% de
leurs colonies
mais c'est un maxime or depuis 2006 ce
seuil est systématiquement dépassé de
manière plus ou moins importante
les abeilles françaises ne sont pas au
top de leur forme cette situation
inquiète en jeu ne concerne pas que la
france la belgique la suisse ou encore
l'espagne ont dépassé les 20 % de
mortalité l'hiver dernier en allemagne
ce chiffre a même atteint les 30% alors
quand stéphane travert déclare que les
dispositifs de surveillance des pouvoirs
publics ne permettent pas de montrer un
déclin des populations d'abeilles
c'était peu stable